okay and it's time for another 13
o'clock movie retrospectives yeah this
is gonna be Excalibur yes good film well
it's weird because we kind of forgotten
all about this when why did we even
think about this I don't even remember
no just trying to think it was think of
some really cool movies that we saw when
we were kids that I remembered as having
good quality yeah and being kind of
influential yeah back in those days it
was a good British film called Excalibur
I remember seeing this one like I had
seen it on cable as a kid the last time
I saw it was in my high school English
class yeah
in 1990 I guess it was it was probably
my senior year I think the last time
that I had seen this was been oh man mid
80s yeah I remember there being really
cool I'm looking really good I even
remember the music from you know vigor
yeah it had stuff from life than you
belong so yeah having to do the
Siegfried and stuff like that yeah yeah
it's as as I remembered it it looks good
it's weird because the only thing I
remembered from the last time I saw was
the was the bird eating that dudes
eyeball out yeah that looks like I
realized that was probably a sheep's eye
stuck didn't stuck in a plastic skull
with hamburger in there I was like I
remembered it being gory because I
remember liking mad about it yeah it's
pretty just what I did it's still a
creepy scene all the dead it's yes I've
never gotten how creepy and like horror
movie-esque some of those scenes are
yeah the movie is not one of these
upbeat Hollywood flicks you know about
hey we're Knights on the backs of horses
you don't look at my shiny art now it's
not the whole thing place kind of like a
horror film it does yes some of the
eerie numbers are dreaming and stuff
like that as you know even in the very
beginning you know the birth of Arthur
maybe I should just back up what what
year was this movie made this was made
in 1981 director and it was directed by
John Boorman who fun fact also directed
Zardoz yeah which that's a bunch of
awesome with Sean Connery being very
furry sawed off in his dog boss what
would you call that
speedo yeah yeah he's wearing speed add
to the whole thing Shan he's so like he
looks like he's wearing a bath mat of
pubes yeah he's like hairy when you see
this movie you can't believe that that's
Sean Connery in it yeah well that's
another movie that's the same director
yeah but it's not really anything like
sir no no this one's actually kind of
like a heavy the weird thing about this
movie is that the movie is written well
it's very fast paced it's kind of long
it's the story of Arthur it's pretty
much taken from like the Morte d'Arthur
yeah yeah and some of the other Arthur
and legends the the dialogue all sounds
like it was something out of Shakespeare
yeah the original stories of Arthur
usually written in poetic form yeah so
you can't really make a movie based on a
poem you have to make a screenplay yeah
and if you're gonna make a screenplay
they can't sound like they're from
California so the best thing to do is to
put dialogue in it sounds like it's so
much Shakespeare yeah yeah they'll buy
that and there's no such thing as our
theory in music so what you do is you
use vogner yeah which you know something
out of the needle long stories about
Siegfried which is I guess you can say
Siegfried is almost kind of like the
German Arthur even though he's a
demagogue yeah it works good it looks
like you're seeing something that's very
historical with a fantasy tinge to it
yeah not as fantasy I would say is Lord
of the Rings or anything like that it
looks kind of historically accurate not
really the armor they're wearing is
Renaissance armor well now okay
evidently the director says he's did
that on purpose yeah because that's when
a little more - Arthur with room yeah
because he wanted he said well I wanted
like anachronistic kind of stuff in
there so it couldn't be tied down to one
time period right and it was more mythic
and stuff like that yeah because it's
supposedly set during the Dark Ages
yeah which then there's a bunch of
Renaissance yeah that's Renaissance and
it looks like Renaissance but this
story's being targeted the stories being
told about something happening in the
Dark Ages
yeah and during the dark a Dark Age
England during the time when Arthur was
could have existed who supposedly
existed British soldiers then would have
been Roman soldiers or at least wearing
gear that looked like something out of
Roman out of a Roman legion yeah during
that time you know they didn't have big
plate mail yeah and because that's what
they were wearing in this like super
shiny or a plate mail armor yeah you
know and it is very Ren fest rooking now
the pacing of the movie is very quick
yeah
but seeing it now I see that the
transitions and the edits are very
abrupt so the movie is edited for an
audience that already knows this story
that's what I'm assuming that's kind of
the feeling you don't know the story of
Arthur sometimes you may not click oh
wait a minute yeah that's right at least
10 years have passed by that you know
right there is no sense of the passage
of time well and interestingly you kind
of what I what I read about this now
evidently the original screenplay was
like three plus hours long oh no the
kitten is in here okay so the original
screenplay was like three plus hours
long right when I saw this on HBO as a
kid there was an intermission you got an
F yeah memory yeah back in the old days
like a theaters if I was like I think if
it was over two hours yeah there was
like a 15-minute intermission yeah on TV
we deposit have a clause button back
then so it's like people might not go to
the bathroom at this point are gonna
make a sandwich I make a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich salmon when Americans
have peanut butter and jelly sandwich
yeah toasted there's no but with some
bananas on okay but anyway so the
original screenplay was like over three
hours long and all the students like ya
know and so the version that they ended
up making now the version that we got on
blu-ray which is the generally seen like
r-rated version yeah was what two hours
two and a half hours something like
and it goes pretty quickly though now
there's also a PG version that was shown
on like regular TV that is shorter so I
just see where ethers just bearing down
on what was your name
uh oh [ __ ] what is that whose name he
was just working Arthur's mom yeah
working her over and authors wearing his
plate mail and another fun fact is the
actress that played Arthur's mom and
gets railed by yeah Luther yeah is the
directors daughter yeah I said that must
have been an awkward day I danced with
Dario Argento at Asia Argento oh yeah so
the thing that I noticed about this like
I said other than the gore I didn't
really remember much about like I
remember being gory and I was like that
was really cool because I was into that
kind of [ __ ] while still in that kind of
[ __ ] but I didn't really remember much
about the story other than I was about
King Arthur Penn stuff
one thing I've forgotten is that this
movie is very I think the word I used
was episodic it's not like a real like
yeah it has a narrative like this
happens because of this and then there's
something that I have that yeah but
there's really no it's not it doesn't
flow smoothly yeah it was kind of a mess
in a way yeah it's kind of like scene
this happens in this scene that scene
like ten years later scene ten years
later yes you know there's no sense of a
transition or the path really time and
they don't really tell you like you know
which I guess is okay like you kind of
figure it out me being a white boy you
know with a [ __ ] Anglo American
background the [ __ ] just speaks to me on
an F on an ethnic way I understand the
story you know I understand the story I
grew up with a story you know I
understand the Christian symbolism and
the Germanic overtones in a Saxon type
story you know coming from you know
Camelot and all that crap I
no if a foreign audience like say
somebody from India I don't know if they
would actually understand this movie
because sometimes 10 years has passed
yeah from one scene to the next I'd like
to hear somebody from the audience I
mean does this movie speak to them I
don't know because I've seen some very
traditional movies you know that came
from places like India or Persia like
Persian tales and I see him I kinda
understand the story but a good example
would be like the Russian story what was
the name of that Russian story with the
witch Baba Yaga Baba Yaga
I can see a story about Baba Yaga I can
understand the story but doesn't have a
cultural impact on me oh yeah because
grow up in that culture in the context
so I don't know if somebody from India
if this is an effective movie that they
can so yeah like you understand what's
going on but it doesn't resonate what
doesn't resonate no you don't you know
cultural context yeah another thing I
kind of wonder about this movie is that
it has it kind of makes a lot of the
Christian symbolism pretty overt yeah
fairly over toward the end especially in
the concept of the Holy Grail when
person parsable finds the Holy Grail it
is asked the riddle of the Grail yeah
and basically what the riddle of the
Grail amounts to is I accept theocracy
basically that the king the land and the
Lord let's say yeah kind of like a
re-creation of the Holy Trinity but in a
government sense that the king is God
yeah and that the land is the king and
the king is go it's at the iris
yeah when there is like a lot of it's
it's almost kind of like a conflict but
even though Merlin is kind of pretty
he's not really portrayed as a good guy
but he's not portrayed as a bad guy
either he's kind of a neutral character
yeah well he's like portrayed as a relic
from the that's what I'm saying it's
like a pagan Christian dichotomy -
ceremoniously retired in a tale in favor
of the new Christian era yeah kind of
cool now here's something that I didn't
exactly pick up on we were watching it
but I saw it in a review that I read
was that the birth of Mordred who is
Arthur's son by Morgana because she's
the witch and she disguises her
something she disguised herself as
Guinevere yeah and you know steal
Arthur's see steal Arthur seed like
those Jessie women yes we weird
inbreeding it is there's a lot of incest
you know and it was all portrayed as
part of like black magic yeah yes they
can all like put Glamour's on themselves
and make themselves look like the other
piece someone else so yeah so that's how
that happened so the birth of Mordred
represented the point at which the land
started to decay right because you know
how Arthur started his hair started
getting gray all his knights of the
round table started like in fighting and
there was all this [ __ ] going on then
Lancelot and Guinevere started [ __ ]
and then like everyone in the land start
a rough starve and like their crops
failed and stuff like that so the
symbolism there was that Mordred was
like the representation of this sin that
caused everything to go to [ __ ] there
the funny thing is about Excalibur's
it's a very Christian influenced tale it
is yet but the weird thing is there's
nothing Christian about the tale no it's
actually just very it's very pagan it's
very warrior war that it's a warrior's
of interpretation of Christianity yeah
and once a warrior starts interpreting
Christianity he's gonna interpret it the
way he wants to interpret it not much
Christianity left yeah about kicking ass
in the name of [ __ ] and name of God not
really talking about God God they're
talking about I mean yes there are some
parallels between Arthur and I guess
he's kind of like a god-like figure or
Jesus like figure but really other than
them going to get the Holy Grail and I
think at one in one scene there's like
kind of a Jesus he looking Shroud of
Turin II tiny thing like behind him on
the wall yeah I forgot about that um
other than that I
it's not really a lot of no no now if
you guys like Star Trek and you you're
into those Klingons it kind of reminds
me of the way that Klingon operas were
described yeah yeah like well the thing
is like the guys had honor yeah but only
to a point
yeah there's this whole kind of thing
where let you know like Lancelot was
supposed to be like the purest yeah one
or whatever and then he still ended up
betraying yeah Arthur well that's friend
when you know that when you when you we
analyzed the movie the movies being
based upon writings of Renaissance
educated Christians talking about
basically a pre-christian era yeah and
their noble ancestors before they were
Christians and the emergence of the
first Christian King yeah which is
Arthur and this is a very popular tale
there was no King Arthur very popular
tale in what is now France and England
yeah the original are actually a little
more - Arthur the one this is based upon
was from France probably pretty yeah or
Saxony or something I mean the stories
had been floating around for longer than
that but I feel like that the Thomas
Malory version kind of codified yeah a
lot of the stuff that people think of as
Arthurian legend run nowadays now some
of the stuff that was put in the movie
like there is the whole xcalibur being
the same as the sword in the stone which
some versions and I don't think in
Lemoore d'Arthur I don't think that the
sword in the started xcalibur were the
same sword but some versions of the tale
they are the same sword yeah you know
what I mean because I feel like that's
kind of a nitpick that a lot of people
have doing 2/3 to see which way in the
story that I am the version I remember
Arthur pulls the sword from the stone
that that proves that he was King right
yeah then later on the Lady of the lake
gives him right if you thought what I
thought he was a coward
Excalibur back at the very end so you
can finally give up the ghost
yes well okay so I feel like if you're
gonna make a movie out of it though
that's probably the best thing to do is
to kind of just make a batch those foods
but because otherwise you can have this
sword that sort it's like confusing
right is you really only need one sword
is the MacGuffin of the movie right and
you know what I mean so it doesn't have
to be two things but honestly one of my
favorite scenes in this is well one when
um when Arthur first realized now does
he know okay but that's one thing that
happens is that he's kind of a teenager
still where he's supposed to be even
though the actors 35 because they used
the same actor for Arthur the whole time
like a teenager twenties old aging yeah
but he you know he did a good job so he
pulls the sword out and they're like oh
you're King now and then like all the
Knights were like some of the Knights
are like [ __ ] that and some things are
like oh okay fair enough
and then so they boy this kitten is like
she's very very bumptious
you know so so they start to fight and I
like the scene where the one night
that's the man and I can't remember his
name the blond one where he's he is the
most [ __ ] this I'm that he's not my king
whatever rook but then he's gonna oh
yeah yeah that's like my favorite team
yeah because I'm like I like that Arthur
was kind of like yeah he met chick yeah
you're right I'm not the King member
right yeah well it's because he he
wasn't a knight yeah I'm confusing the
issue no but also he was that was like I
think that was why they they started to
respect him then because he's like I
have the faith I'm gonna like ya here
and I'm gonna you could cut my head off
if you wanted to right but I'm gonna
trust you I'm not sure we get the audio
me background to understand what it is
I'm talking about but no like I said at
the beginning when Arthur is first he's
just a teenager he pulls a sort of stone
and like I said then some of the Knights
want to follow him and some don't
yeah so they started to wage a war over
who was really great yeah and Arthur the
Arthur did defeat his main opponent yeah
but his opponent said I would never
serve you because you're not even a
knight
yeah and he said do you lift yes Knight
he says you're right I'm not a knight so
I can't be the King and he gave you a
mex caliber he says unite me yeah and
then I could be
and then you know now dude we're gonna
kill him yeah he could have killed him
anyway
Yeah right yeah any night he did yeah
it's a pretty awesome kinda like so I
don't know if it was Arthur's faith that
he wouldn't kill him it was his faith in
goodness yeah or because it's almost
like because it cuz the night that's
holding Excalibur almost kind of goes
like a shake it like it's possessing him
or some [ __ ] I don't think it was yeah
but it's maybe that's what he was trying
to get with a stinky I think he was
realizing that it was like a very
awesome moment yeah like a something
historical was happening he did have
Excalibur in his hands
yeah and a guy handed Excalibur over to
him gave it you know handed it over to
him it's like a guy trusted him enough
to hanoks Kali out over to him you know
not I mean he had a caliber in his hands
yeah it could have killed the king and
taking it firms up he did he figured
that this guy must be really worried
yeah United it yeah and the fact that he
had enough respect for that guy that he
trusted and trusted him to do even
though that guy was conflicted it was
didn't want to be Kane you know I mean
poor Katie she's like what I'm just
trying to be in the show
yeah all right um but that seen that
scene I think was really well done and
also the scene where Arthur is first
meets Lancelot and they're fighting
rather than Arthur kind of I mean
everybody knows 0:13 legends not
spoiling anything google apps that we
have some people that are not from
western counties well yeah it's real but
I mean that the scene where you fights
Lancelot and uses Excalibur he's kind of
cheat is what I'm saying
you might as well just let her in
because she's guys trying to claw she's
yeah the way see we don't know she says
smart yeah we can't you can't like keep
her out of anything just I figured out
how that she's like a she's like a red
phone yeah and she's only half size you
still only have like yeah yeah so that
scene of Arthur and Lancelot fighting
we're where Arthur
kind of cheated but then he kind of like
owned up to his like yeah so he got the
sword back
but yeah like I said it's visually it is
like beautiful it's a beautiful movie it
was actually the whole thing was shot in
Ireland so it's all like on location and
yeah like super super the locations are
very nice yeah the movie visually really
does stand up oh yeah actually if it
wasn't for the editing and the
transitions from one scene to the next
this movie would could be the perfect
Arthur movie yeah this is the only movie
about King Arthur I recommend yeah and
like I said you gotta think to one it
was 1981 - you have to think a lot of
these are Shakespearean actor stage
actors yes and the acting is very good
so the the acting is good but it's very
theatrical let's say that it's very
stage II it's it's a very British movie
although the guy the guy that plays
Merlin I think is the most awesome yeah
like he's he's super super funny the
movie kinda has a feel of almost caleca
I wants a Hammer horror movie Oh more
like a Sinbad movie yeah I like the
scary cynic Sinbad yeah it is kind of a
tiger you know stop-motion pls it's all
live-action yeah it looks really good
the armors really nice yeah it looks
like really cool armor yeah the one on
students in several medical and they're
wearing it throughout the entire movie
yeah flanking around I think the water
and stuff you can tell this like their
armors rusting pretty badly
yeah words and when they start searching
for the Grail yeah and this and the cool
thing too is that this movie was almost
kind of like sort of the first big movie
for a lot of really iconic British
actors you got your Patrick Stewart you
got Helen Mirren it plays the the evil
witch Morgana you got Liam Neeson yeah
it's kind of his first a young Lea a
major role yeah and it was weird because
we first saw him in the movie and I
didn't really remember him being in it
and I was like sounds like that looks
like Liam Neeson I'm like no because of
him some angles it didn't yeah and he
had that weird like man bond thing going
on
sound of like I didn't think it was but
then I when I heard him talk I was like
yeah that's Thailand and that dude can't
remember the name of the dude that
played Merlin Nicol Williamson the guy
that played Merlin he was in a [ __ ] ton
of movies after that too and you know so
there was just like tons and tons of
people that were in this that went on
too much the movie looks really good
it's got a really good feel to it I put
it right underneath Conan one yeah
and it's a similar kind of thing like I
said the editing of it I don't know if
I'd call it at the editing but something
like that it's it's a little jarring
yeah because it covers a lot of ground
in a very short time yeah and it kind of
assumes familiarity with the source
material like I said so like if you
don't really know I mean it's not that
you couldn't follow it exactly you have
to pitch it but you really have to pay
attention to like every word they're
saying
you don't know this if you don't know
the Arthurian legends because they cover
a lot of [ __ ] right and remember we were
first watching it and we were like 15
minutes into them Tammis need to cover a
lot of ground yes already
that's [ __ ] cuz I hadn't seen it since
I was a kid and I didn't realize how
fast paced this movie was it's a long
fast paced movie yeah well because
basically you're going from Connecticut
Arthur's conception right yeah who his
dad was yeah cuz the whole part with
Luther Pendragon and all that at the
beginning and then you know him like
disguising himself as some other dude so
he could go [ __ ] wait yeah and mess
up a whole truce that he just yeah did I
mean how just did the troops and how he
got the sword out of the stone yeah how
he fought his way into becoming King
once he got it yeah how he made the
round table how he met or Lancelot yeah
then it went on to how Camelot got
screwed up
yeah and that was like a long part of
the movie yeah how they met pert how how
Lancelot met parcel first of all yeah
and how parsable actually became at
night yeah ever that yeah and then what
kind of night possible ended up being
and then not a sensitive one really yeah
and then how how everything started
going to shake all the [ __ ] with Morgan
Mordred being born and his Marjorie
growing up and then they then how he put
all the the knights of the round table
on the Grail quest yeah and that took a
long yeah and then how and why parsable
was the only one that actually found the
Grail brought it back yeah and then how
Arthur was able to use the Grail of a
jerk Juvonen himself and get the land
back together so he could fight his evil
son never come him and then how Arthur
died and how the sword was returned to
the lady of the lake to wait for the
next please realize that it to save
England it took you almost as long to
just give that brief synopsis as the
movie no no I meant that like you'd like
just saying that I was like wow I'm
tired just thinking about all that is
that the movie is crammed crammed full
of plot yeah a lot of [ __ ]
the good thing about it is that it's
never boring no it really it doesn't
linger no it doesn't [ __ ] around on any
one point it's just kind of like we got
this allez Liang's to the next bang the
only wasted space and this is a brief
interlude of our third meeting meeting
his wife and there's really not much of
that there's not much of it no that's
the only scenes in this that aren't kind
of action-oriented yeah no more his
sister Morgana
yeah half sister his half sister were
gone Frodo goth attire I mean yeah
there's I think the very godly looking I
can see from that point on all gothic
chicks kind of looked like that for many
years I have to say that yeah Helen
Mirren that got metal breastplate things
she wears that's [ __ ] rad yeah she's
wearing fishnet black fishnets and yeah
yeah in the hair and everything it was a
pretty gothic look and she was all she
was all up in Merlin's business one one
one earned that black magic and all that
[ __ ] talking to the dragon
what was that language they were
speaking up middles
no is old Irish old Irish the terms they
were easy well sort of it was kind of
like
bastardized old Irish because when I
first was first watching the movie and
the black magicians like Merlin and
Morgana were doing the charm of making
yeah she sounds kind of dirty but like
the way they were saying I was like that
sounds kind of like Welsh but it's
actually old Irish which I guess is a
sort of sort of related yeah so yeah so
it is sort of a real language and it
does kind of being something it's
something about a dragon or whatnot but
like I said the whole thing about Merlin
is that even though he's portrayed as
like he teaches her how to do black
magic and [ __ ] like that but he's not
really a bad guy I mean he's not really
a good guy either right like I said he's
a very ambiguous character uh but I
think the guy that plays Merlin I think
he kind of steals the memory right I
would like to ask somebody who from a
non-western country to watch this movie
and give us a report whether or not
thinking of they can follow it what they
think of it maybe something from India
yeah yeah well yeah like to see what
they see I'm always kind of curious
about how people that are raised in one
culture like perceive how I never see
this other cultures mythology yeah and I
mean are they even there were Americans
I mean obviously you know what most of
us came from Europe but since yeah the
past so you know the Arthurian legends
are kind of like are there we were in
sagas yeah we grew up with a market
ology yeah it would be interesting but
yeah it's I definitely think this is
probably the bet they don't make a lot
of King Arthur if they do a movie yeah
although I know the think they made one
recently I hadn't haven't seen it yeah
but it couldn't been good we we heard
about it thank ya yeah far as I'm I'm
not gonna [ __ ] on something
yes far as I know this is to go to
Arthur movie and I remember liking this
very much when I saw it on cable like I
said most because it was gory it was a
hit I remember everybody knew about it
when it came out well it was over and
over again well when it came out in
theatres it was like the number one
movie for quite a while so you know I
mean it was 1981 the movie looks cool it
really looks it looks cool it's cool
story and you know we have it we have it
on Blu right now and it really does look
beautiful the background yeah the
music's fantastic yeah and like I said a
lot of the gore ends like with the hip
but hitting each other with axes and
maces and [ __ ] like that that [ __ ] looks
real
yeah it looks like they're really
beating this [ __ ] I'll tell you that
there's that one scene I think they kind
of ruined it and that was when the when
Arthur broke his sword on Lancelot's
breast way yeah remember that he threw
Excalibur back in that little table yeah
I was like this was a little stream yeah
he turned his back on it he's ditching
it Merlin you know Merlin's like oh
you've done it now you [ __ ] move
Arthur and in the background you see the
lady of the lake in the background
behind it just right underneath the
surface of the water looks so eerie yeah
it looks like a corpse yeah down just
underneath the surface of the water it's
it's bringing the sword up to him now he
turns around they show a next the next
shot is you see like a camera angle of
them looking down into the water and
she's very obviously superimposed into
the water yeah I think it ruins that
shot they never should have directly
showed the lady oh it would have been
away creepier if you had never seen her
face right just that at a slight
distance just that body underneath the
surface with the sword coming up out of
the water and never see just show the
close up because I list the whole
mystery of like what the [ __ ] is she
doing in there why does she have that
sword what is this about she's you know
they're not yeah that's what I mean she
guards Excalibur yeah yeah but it's like
because most of the movie they just kind
of showed her hand sticking up with your
sword in it or something like that so
yeah I agree with you on that they
probably should should have never showed
a close-up of her face even if they'd
have looked down at her they should her
hair just should have better her face or
you couldn't see her yeah and he should
have been a real woman or at least a
mannequin underneath the water yeah
that's not the show they should have
trohman who was high and dry
superimposed over over some water yeah
over the surface of the water didn't
look real yeah she was she looked like
she was you know out of a damn shampoo
commercial yeah baby of the lake so they
were like basically when you just when
you see the lady of the lake now she's
portrayed she's basically a Valkyrie
yeah okay something real similar they
shoulda left is where you could only
kind of see her at a distance on her and
she never came out of the water
yeah thought about it was something kind
of scary like Samara from them yeah no
there wouldn't you be freaked out
woman just a pure collar warden gives a
sword here freak out
damn I want that would be a ghostly
apparition so it shouldn't have been a
pleasant vision from heaven it shouldn't
something disturbing yeah ugly but just
eerie yeah oh yeah now I sway with me
now I'm imagining the whole thing Arthur
thing like totally redone as it's creepy
well it was creepy the way it was done
yeah and there was only the headlight
spots but the whole first half of the
movie with Pendragon you know yeah that
was a very dark yes see ya basically
rape to the woman well yeah not
basically right because he was disguised
as her husband yeah so she didn't know
me that [ __ ] the music it's all dark
it's at night stab each other yeah and
like I said the whole the whole sequence
at the end with Percival looking for the
Grail yeah and then he finds all those
nights hanging from the trees and the
birds are eating them yeah and the [ __ ]
even the [ __ ] with Mordred like in that
[ __ ] weird ass armor armor that he
had it was gold and looked kind of like
a cupid sorta yeah and he was and he's
getting it on with his mom and his mom
turned into an old lady because she used
up all her magic so he strangled her and
threw her away they need some family has
our berries in Arthurian tongue
it has a very satanic anyway okay so I
hope you enjoyed her rambling discussion
of Excalibur yeah the 1981 King Arthur's
yeah that bit the movies still good to
watch if you've never seen it get it on
blu-ray or you can get cheap yeah watch
it and get back with us it's pretty good
I like it yeah I liked it a lot more
than I remembered
yeah I still like the opinion if
somebody say like an India what they
think of it somebody's not familiar with
the legend yeah
just to see how if it translates oh no
well and I know I want to know how easy
it is to follow for someone or it
doesn't if it isn't familiar at that
story yeah we can follow it because you
know the story yeah we can fill it again
I don't think a person that really knows
the story could follow it with that in
it probably not not easily they like I
said it's crammed yeah it's chock full
of plot is what it is if you like Baba
Yaga I well you know what Baba Yaga that
whole thing is so awesome
Russian mythology in general house have
chicken feet and it turns but see you
just have to roll with it man you can't
roll [ __ ] like that like how's that
chicken feet how do was it born which
chicken fingers a house like that born
or the bill more chicken feet or did
someone put chicken feet on it yeah I'm
assuming that because it's Baba Yaga's
house and she is a witch she made that
she made it have chicken feet for
whatever reason she has a chicken foot
fetish and she's like she likes chicken
feet so much that she wanted her
mustache so she knows a kid dubbed in
English yes and they would just show it
to kids and well that's why I like in
feet skittish that's why they had so
many so much good stuff for mst3k
because if I know you guys who have
listened to the show a lot probably know
but I'm a huge mst3k fan and the one
they did of Jack Frost
yeah like the Russian the Rousseau
Finnish mythological movie they did
about nastinka and the and Baba Yaga was
in that she wasn't like the main
character and that was a man playing
that witch - yeah like like he could
another one that they did to you and I
was a kid that was one of my favorite
episodes they took that [ __ ] was
hilarious and finished movies really
yeah they were they're gorgeous - what
you're actually done they look really
good back in the day they would take
them and then rename them I'm trying to
pass him off as something that they
weren't like they they gave one Russian
one Russian one had a blonde guy and he
had big fur coats he's always up in the
ice
you sealing around they're telling you
that this is Sinbad they did that one on
Mystery Science Theater yeah and I'm
going bad cuz you know I was all let
those seen there yeah right Harryhausen
Sinbad's that's not best and better send
that in the snow what's up same guys
don't happen to ask that white yeah that
[ __ ] went over a lot Thank You kitten
out she's crawling around that box of
interest all right so that's our latest
movie review hope you enjoyed our
silliness and seven about chicken feet
remember to check out our patreon and
all that business you can also give us a
one-time donation on PayPal if you would
like to there's a link on the blog and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective see you later